toutes les femmes son apport à la cooper
c'est vrai vous notamment l'épousé
qu'est-ce qui la tue particulier les
beaux c'est vraiment bon acteur mais là
il réalise le film il est pas qu acteur
il est aussi réalisateur c'est vrai je
me kiffe encore plus du coup vous avez
aimé bradley cooper acteurs vous allez
adorer bradley cooper réalisateur son
premier film à la fiche depuis quelques
jours et déjà un hit star is born
avec dans le rôle de la star consacré
lady gaga
[Musique]
il
la presse est galvanisé le public
survolté gaga exalté mais qui est ce
bradley cooper qui déchaîne les passions
c'est quelqu'un qui a toujours été là on
dit aussi que d'un seul coup il est
devenu cette star de very bad trip
depuis le carton mondial de cette
comédie gay régressive
bradley cooper surprend tout le monde
car il sait jouer
il joue la comédie il est très bon dans
les comédiens jouent dans les drames les
très bons moments dans les drames il
sait chanter
il sait danser maintenant il s'est
réalisé et en plus il nous a parlé
français
est ce que vous vous avez trouvé votre
voix en faisant ce film pas encore non
je ne sais pas j'ai c'est un décès
peut-être que je suis en train en plus
en plus se trouver mon poids
jusqu'où va-t-il aller comment s'est-il
réinventer ici un grand réalisateur
était né le monde entier l'a découvert
en plein intermondes vie de garçon ça
s'appelait very bad trip une histoire de
mec
les filles sont très très mise à la
tendance ils vont clairement cddb dit
qu'ils vont la gueule et qui font
n'importe quoi
on imaginait bradley cooper lancé dans
une carrière de gros bourrin raté on
avait affaire à un jeune premier
studieux c'est un bosseur
ça c'est clair c'est il est très
intelligent il est très doué mais il
n'est pas là par hasard c'est le produit
d'énormes choix d énormes sacrifices et
d'une volonté extra humaine il fallait
le voir étudiants poser des questions au
premier rang à de niro ocean pen dans
l'émission inside the actor's studio le
premier de la classe a pris des notes
les conseils de ses maîtres c'est dans
la série alias qu'il les a appliqués
souvenez vous il était le meilleur ami
est un peu amoureux transi de jennifer
garner c'est là qu'on a vraiment eu pour
la prince a le visage de bras les coupes
ariete son beau garçon mais pas non plus
le très beau garçon qui était michael
vartan et c'est quelqu'un qui a gagné en
fur et à mesure de sa carrière à
hollywood ce statut de grand beau gosse
d'hollywood
il a même été pris en flag de roulage de
pelle à carrie bradshaw dans un épisode
de sex and the city à l'aîné
on imaginait bradley cooper embarqué
dans une carrière de beau gosse papier
glacé encore raté on avait à faire un
acteur un vrai fou la carrière dont 20
du groupe ares c'est de jouer contre
l'image existants pas tomber dans le
piège de la romcom facile ni du buddy
movie on l'a vu partir à l'assaut de
films d'auteurs oscarisable chez david
o.russell avec happiness thérapie joy
américaine bluff et surtout chez le
grand clint eastwood avec american
snipers tout est dans le titre
[Musique]
plus gros succès 10 août aux états unis
350 millions de dollars au box office
nomination à l'oscar pour bradley cooper
et carton plein dans l'amérique
républicaine comme il incarnait cette
icône d'amérique conservateur il est
devenu en fait le pont entre ces deux
états unis c'est le mec qui plaît aux
démocrates et aux républicains
est ce ça qui a vraiment accélérer sa
carrière bradley cooper américain de
base complètement raté la france
découvrit un soir de jt qu'il était un
être raffiné capable de parler notre
langue
j'ai pris à l'action provence en fait
c'étaient des universités aux états unis
a giflé la change entre universités là
bas j'ai habité avec une famille
française qui parlent que le français
c'était obligatoire pour moi apprendre
la langue mais c'était bien j'avais la
chance
bravo de cet effort en tout cas bravo
bradley vous êtes décidément le meilleur
de la classe
c'est donc logiquement qu'il s'est mis à
1000% à la réalisation
[Musique]
- 16 bradley cooper 43 ans est désormais
acclamé pour son remake d'une étoile est
née classique hollywoodien qui met en
scène l'ascension d'une star trois
versions existent déjà
1937 avec janet gaynor 54 avec judy
garland 2,76 à barbra streisand
désormais 2018 avec lady gaga s'attaquer
à un mythe comme star is born
c'est pas rien c'est s'attaquer en gros
morceaux de la cinéphilie américaine un
gros morceau même de la culture
américaine je pense que c'est ça on dit
pas mal sur lui pour la presse
américaine
aucun doute il faudra compter avec
bradley cooper la warner l'a bien
compris qui compte faire de cooper un
réalisateur de son écurie comme un
certain clint eastwood pour la studio ça
marche et c'est très important d'avoir
des réalisateurs phares des réalisateurs
stars des réalisateurs phares et si tu
as un comédien qui s'éprouve et déjà
rentable qui dit j'ai envie de devenir
réalisateur
mais c'est l'or dans leurs mains
désormais tous les regards sont tournés
vers une certaine cérémonie cet hiver
est-ce que c'est son année à oscar oui
clairement ça l'est parce qu'il dit le
film a eu un tel succès d estime à
venise qui est la langue de rangement
des oscars il aura à quelque chose il va
pas finir 10019 sens aux noces car dans
son foyer
les paris sont ouverts pour l'instant le
plus grand fait d'armes de bradley
cooper aux oscars c'est ce qu'elle fit
le plus retweet et de l'histoire
et oui même pour ça il est le meilleur